what should I create with my bubbles today oh oh right I
can't speak normally as
I expected it's lonely with no one else around as
I expected it's lonely with no one else around
Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
Oh, wait.
My screen's not on.
Give me a sec.
Let me put this back to Niki.
Hello, everyone.
Before we begin, a huge shout-out to Niki for the sponsor
for today's stream.
It isn't the end of the year without Niki's stream, am I
right?
So thank you again for God it's the victory, Niki, for the
sponsor.
Today is a very special update that just dropped today.
campaign siren um the commander is speaking right now i'm
literally here siren it's okay i'm here now you don't have
to worry um but yes apparently um there's a new character
dropped tomorrow uh so there uh there's no gotcha pulls
today uh but the new year event does start today um and uh
there's a lot of free stuff to look forward to as we all
know we all love free things i believe there is There's
around a hundred free polls.
There's a new story event.
And also new costumes.
Like I said, there's a new character, Snow White.
But she is dropping tomorrow.
Not today.
I don't know if we could see Snow White in the...
Oh yeah, 13.
No, this is not Snow White.
But I mean, we could do a poll just for fun.
We might not have Snow White, but we could maybe...
We could post something just for fun.
Yeah, so a hundred free polls.
We love free stuff.
Part one of the event does start today, which is 30th
December.
The new character Snow White drops tomorrow.
Part two of the new event starts at January 6th.
Yeah, so like I said, oh, we can, yeah, oh, he's here in
the, oh, yeah, I'll show you guys in the, the Nikipedia.
Well, obviously, that's not the Nikipedia.
Let me figure out.
Oh, there it is.
It's right here.
Nikipedia.
It's like a Wikipedia, but for women.
where is she snow wet oh wait i can just search you up snow
wet oh snow what oh there she is believe she is which
version is she she is have heave arms i believe this one
right is this the newest one or we have not achieved any Oh,
the third one?
Okay, the third one.
Heavy arms.
There we go.
Eve arms.
Wow!
It's heavier yet.
Yet.
Okay, wait.
What's version is this one?
Oh, this is... Oh, this is when...
Oh, this was before she had PTSD.
Before... Before the light disappeared from her eyes.
You know?
Before she...
Yeah, before she got PTSD from the war.
Yeah, that definitely looks so...
heavy yeah so yes this will she will be dropping tomorrow
yeah when she had hope and light in her eyes but this will
this snow white heavy arms will be dropping tomorrow you
will be able to do some pulls on her tomorrow but don't
worry you have 100 free pulls you want to support this
stream and the sponsor feel free to click on the like link
long link pinned in my chat and under description below it
helps out the stream a lot and um you get there's it's very
um i feel like it's very beginning friendly when it comes to
like giving you free stuff there's they always give a lot of
free pulls so um there's nothing to worry about that all
right what about view mode whoa
whoa happy new year
what a great way to end the year guys happy new year Oh,
she's cute, though.
Look at cute.
For those who are new to Nike, I have the other sponsor by
Nike several times, but it is a highly immersive anime
sci-fi RPG shooting game, and you can play it on both PC and
mobile, so you can download it on the mobile, and you can
download it on PC.
You can click on my link, pin on my chat to ask to choose
which one you want to download your game from.
There's a lot of...
You've done a lot of collaborations, Chainsaw Man, Neeraer,
ReZero, Resident Evil, I remember the Resident, we were, uh,
Eva, we were, we did the Eva collab, we did the Resident
Evil collab, um, everything, and, uh, but yeah, we are here
to recruit Nikes, who are these beautiful, beautiful women
here to fight for us to grab, get the world back.
Um, what else, what else?
Uh, oh yeah, so basically this this uh because we were there
for the third year anniversary um this basically uh carries
on from the story from the third year anniversary remember
when we had a vr chat thing with uh nike uh the sponsor of
that and how someone died and i was like don't worry guys i
can save her and then i started throwing money at her but
then she never recovered um so it follows the story from
that it was she's dead like one of the main one of the i
would i don't know if i should say is it main She's gone
now?
She's, yeah, like a lot of apparently a lot of Miki's died,
so we're following the story from that.
And they actually killed off, like, they actually killed off
one of the main characters from the storyline.
And now we are following Snow White's story.
Yeah, apparently quite a couple of characters died too.
And it continues from that plot.
they you know we we didn't i know it's crazy but we didn't
succeed with the rapture queen i know after everything i did
in 3d we didn't win the fight i know it's actually crazy so
um so we're focusing on that story of snow white um i mean
you know what even though even though snow white's not here
i will do a poll in her honor i will do yeah the rapture
queen apparently killed a lot of people there's like 13
hours of this maybe i'll be lucky i'll do a one pull in her
honor she'll be like she'll basically be snow white for me
she'll be my substitute snow white we oh i didn't get
anything i didn't get anything it was all purple it would
give me the little shiny shiny at your service
you and turn you to gems.
Leave it to me.
One, ten.
Almost.
They both have the number one in it.
It's almost the same, guys.
Oh my god.
How is she purple?
She might as well be a blue.
I swear every sponsor stream, I get Ether.
Every time she might as well be a blue.
I promise to meet with my new teacher today.
Your orders, please.
to why she earful all right do my best you know one wait how
many gems do I have you know one two if they're both it's
it's the same it's almost the same they just have a zero on
both of them so you know one zero what two zero it's like
one pull god fucking what what what i will take you safely
to your desired destination
i fucking did it oh my the fake out yes not the purple and i
was like oh i didn't get it Two I told you I got it.
It's just that easy.
It's just I she's literally snow white She's she's white
snow.
I mean as in the color white guys She she's she's wearing
white snow white wears white Practically the same thing
guys.
They both wear white
See you guys practically the same I may be a mass production
model.
Oh my god, it's just that easy, guys.
She's also heavy as well.
Look at that.
Close enough.
Is she good, though?
Is she had to?
Oh, hey, Mihara.
The purple Mihara, though.
Oh my god, she was the second one.
I couldn't even pull again if I wanted to.
I'm fucking broke, guys.
I can't even pull another one if I wanted to.
that wait is she even good she's decent okay is she better
okay let me grab the outpost real fast then yay free stuff
okay do i have do have a free wipeout yeah i did okay nice
and i'll claim again all right okay but let's grab all the
free stuff first guys i need to i gotta do my dailies real
quick guys i got it all right so all right give me a sec i'm
just doing my dailies real quick oh my points.
Ooh, look at that.
Alright, so yeah, if you are, for the new years, one of the
free things they give us is this.
I already did my gotcha attempt, my gotcha pose, but when
you do this, it gives you free gems and everything.
What else?
Is there anything else I need to grab?
This is a new event, the Arc Guardian.
So it starts at December 29th and ends on January 19th,
guys.
Remember to do it before it's too late.
A limited event.
yeah it's literally free gems you gotta grab them free is
free chat free is free we all love free stuff claim all my
god look at all these free stuff all right okay so i was
like oh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you no
no jealousy for okay so this is my team i would have
cinderella and siren as my top ones and then i would have uh
i think it's like private privity and oh my god who else i
think it was privity uh what the who else was on my oh now
was it nava this is not the rented one right no i rent her
uh try to remember my guys give me a sec i need to know if i
should adjust my team okay this will be my team all right
yeah okay oh yeah no okay it's this is this guys do i
replace any of them do i replace it i know are rented so
like i don't care about them so it'll be novel modernia or
privity do i replace uh replace them with rid modernia fella
is she good though i'll start
the end is good her
from the yeah but i can level her i can make her better i
will feed it lots and lots Lots of, I guess, ramsticks.
Oh, she's better?
Okay.
I'll start feeding her ramsticks later.
Alright, thank you.
I just needed a note.
I'll...
I'll feed her ramsticks later.
Oh, wait.
Um...
Okay, so I replaced...
Who did I replace?
I replaced Novel with...
Wait, should I replace Mordernia with...
Brid?
Wait, no, I can't replace Novel with her, because, like,
she's the three-bullet thing, and I don't have any three
bullets.
Should I replace her with Modernia, then?
JK, I know I just said all of that, but now I'm replacing...
I'm replacing Modernia with...
Yeah, I need her thingy, this thing.
So, shouldn't I remove...
I should replace Novel?
I should?
Oh, I need a...
Oh!
oh okay i'll never mind i guess i'll replace her goodbye
goodbye goodbye knob okay anyway back to back to the
sponsored version i got really distracted i had to oh we
don't quit don't quit guys this was very important okay i
had to know um i assume the costume as well is not live yet
so um because snow white is coming in tomorrow so I assumed
the yeah I was oh yeah I should level her give me a second
let me feed her real quick oh wait I want to see her wait oh
my god she brought props she brought a desk to the fight to
the surface I'm surprised this outfit whoa is really
comfortable oh really this you're wearing a corset yeah yeah
yeah you're wearing a corset what do you mean it's very
comfortable my gosh okay let's feed her this is a great
start thank you please take my ramsticks what a meaningful
day please take my please take my usb all right let's put
her stuff on all right wear this and this when you need
shoes girl you really need shoes okay and then we level her
level this up all right not enough materials but don't worry
don't worry i have other stuff to upgrade yeah all right and
then level up this all right nice we should be good oh wait
do i have a cube i do not have a cube that's okay that's
okay we don't have to worry yeah i she's my new girl i just
got her she's my snow white she is my oh wait i should see
how she fights how does she fight oh she's like a Ah, Jesus,
what the- she has a knife on her gun.
Oh my god, she brought a- an animal.
Dude, too- Wait, is that a rabbit?
Oh my god, I'm shooting next to a rabbit.
Is this a shotgun or a- Oh, and she brought coffee, too.
Yeah, she has a bayonet.
Someday, the train's here.
That's crazy.
Anyway, let's get into this story.
so the new update for the the story um but yeah huge you get
you shout out again to uh Nikkei for the sponsor as well
it's really great working with them throughout the year um
they've they supported me uh for so long like we were there
since the very beginning uh of Nikkei when it first came out
and now it you know we're all the way to the third year
anniversary for Nikkei as well as you know being being
sponsored for the end of the year for their newest new year
celebration Very excited to, you know, work with them again
for this.
Anyway, before we begin, I have, we have to watch the PV for
all the new stuff that's going on.
I almost forgot the PV.
Sorry, I got too excited doing the pulls.
So let's watch the, let's watch the video for all the new
updates, guys.
I believe it is.
Whoops, not that.
Whoa, whoops.
Oh, sorry.
So if you guys saw all those things bouncing around, it's
because I...
I had to like, I actually moved one of the browsers.
All right, here you go.
Oh, there she is.
She departed without any regrets.
No regrets.
I mean, they lost the war though.
We lost the battle.
We can't save everyone.
What then, pray?
Are we to tuck our tails betwixt our legs like hounds
defeated and slink That was me!
That was me!
How
are you doing?
Are you okay?
Look, Lilith!
Oh no!
Lilith!
No!
She's one of the people that died, right?
I'm a goddess.
I have to do this.
This time, I will grant you true rest.
There she is Oh There she is she's here for revenge now you
go girl you got this I believe All right, don't worry.
I got her to see my snow white
My substitute
She's she's just like her they both wear white guys.
She's just like her not it's literally the same guys it's
like oh wait look free stuff yay free stuff i assume like
the storyline for this is oh my gosh oops sorry when's the
story mode street i'm i'm literally doing it oh wait here
you go that's me i just know what
oh i just realized you can hear so this is what it's like to
be able to move your body freely oh yeah because she's
always like geared up i'd forgotten what this felt like
considering your condition it's impressive any of you were
able to move around on the surface what a complete mess yes
spoiler spoiler pilot i mean too fair every sponsor is a
spoiler because we're always checking out the new stuff not
only that scarlet she's free now mass-produced model in its
current state it's unbelievable yet despite all that you
both kept fighting most admirable you're right we are
admirable at present your body has been completely repaired
and even enhanced oh yeah repaired take it off you're
repaired now do you like them we try to replicate them as
closely as we have repaired you you don't need to wear more
armor particularly strong they're a bit too light in fact
weight has yeah they're technically robots that's why
technically you don't have to feed them technological
advances begin with improvements in weight even so they feel
far too light and seem to like and i feel like i'm telling
you they're not android cyborgs me up with additional
weapons and ammunition Finally succeeded in increasing
performance while reducing weight.
What's the point of making it heavier again?
The more weapons, the better.
Oh, I like her.
Fine.
Road me up to the limit.
As you wish.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
So, yeah, side boy.
How are Scarlet and Rapunzel?
I managed to keep them alive.
Strictly speaking, their brains are being housed in the
brain shelter.
More DPS.
Their bodies are beyond repair.
and cannot be used that's a relief then when will they
receive their new bodies that won't be possible what what
eden doesn't possess the technology to manufacture nikes i
don't understand wait how then what have you been doing all
this time yeah what's your job repair pre-existing bodies
but creating one from scratch is beyond our capabilities
it's similar to how the arc handles Oh my god, we gotta call
an emergency.
We gotta transport them to another country.
However, I was merely an MMR researcher.
There was no way I could smuggle out Nikkei production
technology on top of everything else.
That technology is entirely monopolized by the big three.
So, what happens now?
We'll have to obtain it from the Ark.
We gotta go to the Ark?
That guy is making his way to Eden.
I'm planning to have him request the Ark to transfer Nikkei
production technology to us.
And you're okay with doing that?
Of course I'm not okay with it.
It hurts both my pride and feelings.
The same applies to Johan, obviously.
However, during our battle against the Queen, I realized
something.
We should have set aside our bullheaded pride and
conviction, and just focused on becoming stronger.
if we had shared our technology with you and learned yours
in return things might have turned out a lot differently
it's something I regret though at this point such insights
are pointless I feel the same way I took the Queen too
lightly I thought of her as something that existed literally
the rapture and i figured that would be enough she's not
real i regret it can't be real if we obtain the nike
production technology from the ark noah can be restored as
well we can only hope what about heran and isabel are they
okay oh i'm sorry oh no it is we still have their brains
right those two i never thought i would say we still have
their brains right they went out like true goddesses we we
still said the line guys we can regrow the brain and we have
one of them right we can truly we can regrow the brain
thanks for everything you've done
bed and stairs at the ceilings.
Her thoughts are all over the place.
However, the mental turmoil soon settles, condensing in
there a single thought.
Kill the queen.
The one who desecrated a beautiful white flower, Lilis.
Kill the queen, no matter what.
Still white, close to her eyes and falls asleep.
For some reason, she feels like she's about to dream of the
past.
oh that's me that's me guys wait is that snow white wait oh
is this one this is like back in the the past see i lived oh
my god it's flashback time also um how do you access guys my
nike veterans How do you access the storyline view before we
begin?
A hundred years?
A hundred years ago?
I assume it's campaign, right?
Okay, it's...
I want to know.
It's in the archives.
Oh, it's under campaign.
Outpost.
Oh, it's outpost.
Okay.
Because I am supposed...
I forgot to do one thing.
I am supposed to do one thing.
supposed to look at storyline view storyline view uh in
commanders oh command center outpost base archives command
center enter
storyline oh okay we got it so we are supposed to look at
all of these too.
I almost forgot about this part.
So we can understand, like, what's going on.
We might get them back some Nymphide Repuzzle, aka Doki.
Thank you, that's super shy.
Uh, Kat.
Thank you.
So, we are supposed to look at...
No records available.
They become...
Oh.
This story can be played by going through the archives.
Oh!
Okay, so basically This happened, then this, then Wait, what
is this?
What is this called?
Old tales Oh
What do I get out of it?
Oh Oh, I don't have money I Yes, guess not
at even because I don't have I'm broke I don't have any
films oh I have no films never mind but but for anyone that
does have films um for anyone that does have films make sure
to check out these events so you know what's going on before
you do art guardian because apparently doing these will lead
will make you understand this more Oh,
can I?
Is it for free?
Alright, the shop.
There's film?
Okay, free.
Oh, we gotta buy this first.
Where is film?
That's battery.
Take as much time as...
Are you looking for something?
Oh, hey, that's why I have this.
That's a dog.
Oh, in the event shop.
Sorry, I went straight to the shop.
Wait.
We event shop in the event.
Oh, you mean this event?
Alright, we'll go to the shop.
I don't need the shop.
Wait, I think I have enough.
Yay!
Let's go.
We can only afford one.
Alright, we can...
We'll pick one.
I'll let you guys decide for me okay it's here I was like
how do I get back all right you guys get them I can only
afford one so which one would be the best which one would be
the best there's several there's red ash part one red ash
part two do I should go straight to part two yeah over zone
or red ash I'll do the part one red ash Old Tails is really
good too.
I'll do it though.
Red Ash.
Okay, go straight to part two.
Alright.
Alright, here you go.
Unlock.
Oh.
A scent of the bakery.
Whoa.
Oh,
my God.
She's humming.
Oh, that's good.
go yeah my bones will be buried in the earth and your
hometown
whoa hey are you listening to this old wait that snow white
that's baby snow white she's so little show some respect
she's so tiny Oh my god.
Come here.
Oh my god, she's small white.
Red Hood, I can't breathe.
Could you turn that down?
What was that I just heard?
Surely it couldn't be someone interrupting this fine song
I'm listening to.
The friends I miss.
Even the sky above us is forever gray.
return to our hometown someday.
It's positively effervescent, right?
I feel like I'm getting older just listening to it.
What do you want about?
Besides, most things in life are like a fine wine and only
get better with age.
At any rate, what brought you over here to see me?
I doubt it was because you missed me.
Did you come to borrow my nudie mag?
Whoa, what?
Wait, Absolutely not Yeah, I'm gonna be like That's a child
So what you mean is that you'll be super into it later Wait,
so Okay, what?
Okay, I'm actually curious So they're all brains, right?
They're all brains So why is she?
So does that mean like She's They got a brain of A child And
then like She's like And then it grows up or like does she
does she get like because it's like robots right so like you
know when she gets older do they just like add boobs so so
it's no way that's no way like transfer like her brain to to
that body when she was a child and then they're like well a
hundred years past so technically You're not longer a child
anymore.
So we gotta modify your bot.
Because we gotta get some upgrades going on.
Right?
It's called upgrades.
You're right.
So today, upgrade their bodies.
I think I've got a good idea of what he's going to say.
Oh, so they can grow.
Okay, because I'm like wondering, like, how did we get her
from, like, how did we go from that to her?
To heavy arms.
It's just a friendly hug Call it what you want.
I'm just curious Because those two seem like not the same
people Like the tip the two show whites they don't seem like
the same person
Hmm are you two practicing pro wrestling whoa you apparently
have too much time on your hands It's not what you think
That's so, Sindade.
That's me!
Are you guys wrestling?
There's never a dull moment with you two.
That's me.
It's so accurate, too.
That's not what we're doing.
If I may throw in my two cents, wrestling isn't a
particularly useful martial arts discipline against
raptures.
Devoting your time to practicing it will be of little value.
We're not wrestling!
Oh, wrestling, eh?
that headlock of yours isn't too sturdy Red Hood I've got a
few years you could check out for reference if you'd like
Lilith Red Hood is bullying me no I'm not we're practicing
pro wrestling that's what Red Hood said how many times do I
have to say that this isn't wrestling wait what is it then
what are we doing it was not like what are we doing is that
me so am i to take it that red hood is picking on you hey i
would never pick on our precious little snow white oh that's
command oh that's not me that's everyone bro he should be
called commander b or something so i can know which one
commander a and commander b up to you is that everyone oh
that's the commander before i took over that's the legendary
huh here sure until i show up it's the commander um can't be
legendary commander if i'm here guys could you all sit
closer together how come you're all so far apart we're
supposed to be a team if you want us to be chummy then let's
have a group meal the last time we all hung out and had some
grub.
Well, we all ate together just last week.
Yeah, like, we already ate, like, a week ago.
Why are we gonna eat again?
That's so true.
Yo, preach that's so true.
Why do we need to feed our Nikes more food?
I don't remember anything.
I thought you were pretending to black out so you didn't
have to pay the bill.
I agree.
i'm not that kind of person if the commander was yeah if the
commander was so great and he was so legendary why is he
dead i've turned over yeah and why i'm still alive everyone
i have details about our next mission guys thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you good now to get started he's
not hmm not yet to be honest i'm not a fan of our squad's
name goddess squad It's like I don't even exist.
Not yet.
When are we going to commence the briefing?
Wait, this was 100 years ago?
Why is he alive?
Wait a minute.
Okay, wait, wait, okay.
Wasn't this 100 years ago?
How is he alive?
Wait a minute.
They have the technology.
They can rebuild him
Alright Since we know the chronological Okay I unlocked this
area Oh wait what's the minigame?
This is more important Let's move out The archive doesn't
support the minigame No don't say that That's a battle
simulation I love the minigame parts Did they put his brain
in a jar too?
I thought that was served for the women
tends to break the game's balance.
Fair enough.
As for the commander, yes?
Well, you know, no need to spell it out.
I get what you're trying to say.
The commander's fighting skills are...
Yeah, I know, right?
It's so...
Oh, is this the vampire survivors?
Alright, did you make this all by yourself?
Even the artwork?
Yes.
Oh, my gosh.
No, I drew all of this.
What's all your character in game, though?
Huh?
All the others look fairly similar, but your character looks
way different.
How can I put this?
She feels a bit harboring, like some battle-hardened war
dog.
Add an easy mode to it, so you don't need a super invested
account to catch up to now or possibly ever.
Calm down, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I saw that, but I was wondering, do you still get,
like, the same rewards for it?
Or, like, do you get less rewards if you do the easy mode?
I'm getting warm, aren't I?
I knew it's only natural for someone your age to be enamored
with a character like that.
I'm looking for seeing how you get along So are you going to
spot off bad as one lies Like if you believe that in the
creator you better start playing Oh no rewards Okay I'll
still play the regular then Let me play snow white Yeah why
are you getting upset for it?
Let me play Alright Memory of goddess where you destroy a
rapture swarm Oh Oh my god I can never escape roguelites Tap
and drag to move.
Use the weapons equipped by the characters to attack
enemies.
You're defeated when a character's HP is depleted.
Guys, I could never escape.
I always find a way to play a roguelike.
You can choose an item from the...
You can choose an item you own.
The item will level up.
When killing raptures, attract all of them.
Alright, here we go.
We gotta start.
Alright.
Oh, I can only do one.
Oh, I can play a Snow White.
Um, I assume, yeah, I can only do one.
How do I... What is this?
Like...
What is this thing?
Okay, reflector, rapid movement.
Oh, is that like...
Oh, tap... Oh, that's... Oh, that's a D-pad!
Okay.
Let's see.
Enhances increases.
Speed is...
Get the reflector?
Okay.
I'll grab the reflector.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's insane.
Oh, I got the dog tag, too.
Nice.
Maudin has his defense.
That fires that nearby.
I'll get weapon.
Stronger.
Stronger weapon.
Remember what Snow White said?
More weapons, more strong.
Energy sword.
I don't really want...
I'm going to grab the sword.
So they can't get close to me.
Just in case.
I don't know what build I'm doing.
I don't know what build I'm doing, but...
You know, maybe it'll work.
You don't know that.
Maybe it'll work, guys.
Ooh, level two?
I'll grab my gun more.
Will that free will take rain.
We got this.
Oh, can we go?
More DPS.
More win.
More shrog.
Practically doing the least no white build.
Grenade.
I don't need defense.
No, I'll do beef a bit faster.
Just so I can grab my money more.
It's not janky.
Guys, this is peak.
I'm theory crafting right now.
I'm literally theory crafting boomerang.
Wait I could get the oh projectile speed is always good But
can I turn up the speed how oh tab oh okay.
Yeah, we're just gonna turn up the speed Uh projectile
speed.
Oh my god, it's so fast now Wait, I like that feature.
That's very smart.
I like that There we go.
Oh, oh, that's the fastest I can go.
No, I wanted to be even faster.
Uh, HP enhancement, submachine gun.
We'll grab HP.
Having more HP is like having defense if you think about it.
It's literally the same thing.
We'll grab.
Grab the money.
What's this?
Smash model after Puzzle spins and creates an energy.
G-Sphere.
I'll just do more reflector.
I think I have enough, like, attack stuff anyway.
Whoa!
Okay, these guys go so fast.
It messes with me.
Ooh, that... Oh, wait.
Yeah.
You can grab items easier.
Oh, what's this?
Oh!
That's a nuke!
That was the nuke.
Watch me become the next.
The next...
What game is this even called?
I don't even know.
I don't even know what game they made.
They called this mini-game.
Size.
Oh, wait.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, that spooked me.
Okay.
Wait, that's the boss.
We're about to kill the boss.
It's just chilling there.
Okay.
There you go.
It's almost dead.
Oh, man.
Memory of Goddess?
Okay.
I will hit the high score of Memory of Goddess.
Stop running away!
Let me kill you!
Yeah.
Nice!
I got the big, big one.
What did I get?
Goddamn tactical rifle?
Oh my god, I'm shooting everywhere now.
Okay, oops.
I deserve that.
I ran into that.
Alright, fine.
I'll grab defense since it's here anyway.
No, I didn't mean to take the HP.
It's so tiny.
The heart is so tiny.
Okay.
Wait, I have ult?
How do I ult?
What button is ult?
Oh!
Wait, what does my ult do?
What does my ult even do?
Oh, whoops.
I might need actual attacks now.
Oh, it's just...
I just shoot stuff everywhere.
Okay, rapid fire, yeah.
I figured out what my ult does.
I'll do grenade.
Let's start chucking stuff.
Nice.
You have to get close to me.
Alright.
We're good to go.
You can't surround me.
I'm fast as fuck, boy.
Alright, I actually need to grab some stuff, though, here.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Chill, everyone.
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, everyone.
Calm down.
Don't worry.
I'll kill you soon.
Line up.
Line up to get killed by me.
Oh, no.
There's the boss here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm heading over.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Okay, we're just going to casually walk over here.
Oh, everyone is so fast right now.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, calm down, guys.
Yep.
Calm down, everyone.
Okay, we got to be a little slower.
We got, this is way too fast.
This is way too fast.
fast right now.
I can't get away.
Oh.
Oh, I think I messed up my build, guys.
I might have messed up my build.
This might not be a really good build.
Just a maybe.
I I have a feeling I did not do a really good build.
Oh god.
Oh they're so big.
Okay.
Oh there's so many robots.
Oh nice level up.
Uh.
ah more damage maybe more damage so i can get away there's a
heart there there's a heart everything will be fine i just
okay i'll lead them up top so that i can go downstairs oh my
god they can shoot now too wait that's not good okay nice i
grabbed a heart oh that did not heal a lot that really did
not heal a lot
hit it's okay surely another heart will appear oh god oh god
whoa whoa uh beat projectile speed you know that that's
always helpful look see everything is fine yay that's that's
a lot that's a lot of stuff look at that look at that we got
That's a lot.
That's a lot of upgrades, guys.
See, I told you guys.
Their upgrade is fine.
It's so fine.
I didn't get anything from that.
Really?
Oh, I'm just gonna go straight down.
Okay.
Okay, it's okay.
We had so many upgrades.
It's okay.
Maybe there's a heart here somewhere.
Maybe Yeah, there's a heart here.
Oh, God, I'm so lost.
Where am I?
Look at that.
See, I told you.
There's a heart.
Look at that.
Nothing to worry about.
It's like I never lost HP at all.
It's like I never lost HP, guys.
It's magical.
I'm still alive.
That grenade.
needs more graded more damage more damage more damage more
survival right i don't need hp
as long as i keep doing my damage nice all right i'm back to
i'm almost full hp again i just need like several more
hearts how long does this mode last like is there is there
like a specific time that we hit and then are starting will
show up with the demon start showing up as their time frame
yeah more bullets 10 minutes okay we're almost there guys i
told you guys uh grenades
okay nice all right we're literally one minute away told you
i'm a natural when it comes to these games guys all right
then oh god oh god what is going on what what is going on
what is going on why is he just
how is he allowed to just run at me that should be illegal
that that should be illegal that should be illegal you
should not be allowed to just run at my face okay it's fine
should not be like...
Okay, bye.
I just need to grab health real quick.
And I'll go up top.
There has to be like one heart up top.
Just one heart.
Uh, more grenades.
Does someone say more grenades?
You projectile speed.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Where is one singular heart?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, calm down, calm down,
calm down, I gotta grab the chest.
Yeah, defense, yeah, I don't really need that, but yeah, oh
my, okay, Okay, that, like, scared me.
Okay, I'll be a little faster.
And I essentially have room to fucking walk now.
I'll just grab this just for the sake of it.
Oh, my God.
30 seconds, 30 seconds, and then we're...
And then we make it.
30 seconds, and then we're gaming.
There's another heart.
Got it?
Oh, my God.
I'm practically full HP again.
Look at that, I told you!
Yeah!
White should be white.
Look, look!
Hmm?
What am I supposed to be looking at?
Oh, that's so cute.
That's really cute.
I'm just a dog tag.
I just got it.
It's just a dog tag.
What are you so happy about?
Because it means that now I'm officially a member of the
goddess squad.
You do realize what dog tags are meant to be used for,
right?
invocation your name squad stuff like that that's true but
there's something else you're forgetting when we're on the
battlefield there are bullets and missiles flying around
every which way what happens get hit by one as long as it's
not to my head i should be fine it hurt really bad who gave
me pain receptors what more than that if you get hit your
entire body will you're right it hurt like a mother so you
can use your dog oh what there's no way she's she's messing
with me You bet.
It may be small, but it makes for an ape.
There's no way it can block a goddamn missile right here.
You're messing with me.
Yeah, you're pulling my leg.
I should have known you wouldn't fall.
Yeah, I was gonna say that.
A missile's a missile.
It just meant to make you look cool.
Do I look cool right now?
You bet you do.
Super cool.
Yeah!
First try.
First fucking try.
I'm not good.
All right, let's actually go back to the...
Let's go back to the...
Sorry, let's go back to the sponsored version.
Dude, let's go back to the Ark of Guardian.
So after we do the Ark Guardian, we'll check Red Ash out.
If we have time.
Yeah.
Sorry, I saw a rogue like, I had to do it.
I had to do it.
Also, before we do, I actually need to use the bathroom
super duper quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
Back to Ark Guardian.
Back to our flashback.
Papa, Lexi, bite-sized.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Wait, what's challenge?
Oh, it's...
Oh, okay.
So you can grab more stuff for this.
All right.
Missions time.
Wait, not missions.
Enter.
Enter time.
I got there.
I got there eventually.
Let's go and find everyone.
I want to put in Snow White My snow white So we can get rid
We'll get rid of you so I can put Her in The AZX is ready to
depart Guys you think I'm gonna succeed Guys You say I'm
gonna win I hope I hope I win guys I hope I can win Has
there yet been any word from Lilith Or the commander
not yet no I am worried it is the first time we've
experienced what about a little power guys I doubt there'll
be any trouble not with those two that may be true but
considering the circumstances we've been staying in contact
with the United Forces of humanity or rather the central
government they're saying something unexpected came up so
it's hard to get in touch with them right now for We'll just
have to take their word for it.
All right.
And should they still fail to make their appearance?
Where's me?
Where's no one?
I mean, there's me here, but where's other me?
That's rather bold of you.
You said it yourself.
In light of the current situation, those two are
indispensable.
It's obvious the authorities are hamstringing them with
political nonsense again.
If they're just stalling, we should get both of them out
ourselves.
Me thinks thou hast roused the slumbering beast.
God, it's the...
That was how it's thought.
Very well.
If the interim chieftain sayeth so, I have no quarrel.
It's the ye old English.
It makes us sound like a motley crew of mountain bandits.
Alas, this is a most vexing matter indeed.
Though they did not partake in the battle against Anachiro,
that they have not so much as revealed their visages till
now is an offense most unpardonable.
Should they present themselves, I shall chastise them
soundly.
exactly are you planning to scold them you've already been
slammed into the floor and ceiling there's nowhere left for
you to get lodged in she called you weak girl speaking of
anachiro i have a feeling there's more than one heretic i
agree who's the other heritage such a notion those are
fusion experiments i saw in labs me after i read one
shakespeare book yeah she's a media kid for sure fusing
Nikes with raptures.
Anna Chiro must have been their first successful creation.
And considering how much she's accomplished, there's no way
they would stop it, only one.
Frankly, if three additional heretics like Anna Chiro, no,
even just two were to show up, humanity wouldn't stand a
chance.
Oh no, we wouldn't do.
That's precisely why we need Lilith and the commander.
They're steadily growing stronger while we're over here
wearing ourselves down.
Unless something big happens that can turn the tide,
humanity is doomed.
What manner of talk is this?
Did we not achieve victory even without the two of them?
Did they get a brain from, like, someone from the 1500s?
But we had Red Hood with us.
Why does she talk like that?
Doth thy heart yet yearn for her?
Yes.
If they dig up someone from the medieval times, and then,
like, put that brain in her?
She's shown brilliantly and departed of her own free will
with no regrets.
becoming to linger in such moping moping yeah that's what
i'm seeing have maintained a most admirable compote oh she's
just chewy does she remain as she was yes she spends all her
time in the workshop and barely comes out i suppose she
still hasn't gotten over it i can understand how she was
gonna be the poem it's never easy to forget those we've lost
especially why did we say the pope to war why it's only
natural she feels this way oh I was sending the pope to war
since we can't truly know what it feels like to lose someone
so precious I know well how it feels I need must have a word
with her leave her be she volunteered aren't thou so soon
forgetful of thy own utterance we require every able-bodied
soul gather forthwith, even if just one.
Though it may strike harsh, now is assuredly not the hour
for succumbing to despondency.
So must I press them onward, even by force if need be?
I shall take upon myself the part of villain.
Alright.
You go, girl.
I'll leave that to you.
I'm not confident when it comes to such things.
Huh.
Me thought as much.
What do you mean by that?
She called her stupid.
He's like, what do you mean by that?
Gotta go!
She's like, I guess I gotta go to my mission now.
Watch this.
Oh, you don't have to.
See, guys, I'm gaming right now.
One moment, please.
That's me doing it.
Whoa, yeah, yeah.
Train services will not be interrupted.
Whoa.
What do you mean?
Did you not see my cursor move?
We have arrived at your destination.
I did it.
It's been a pleasure escorting you here safely.
So good.
You not see my cursor move?
Is there any within?
No, it's a lie.
Oh, wait, my cursor doesn't show up.
I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, my cursor actually doesn't
show up.
oh this situation doth offer scant hope onto my heart and
grips the hilt of your sword preparing to strike the door
with even greater force
wait i have an idea i'm coming oh that's me other me yeah
because like she's still a child but like like the others
stay the same she literally got upgraded that's precisely
what i was going to ask you what in the world are you doing
well that's a strong-ass kid though what possessed thee to
fling the door wide open so suddenly because they didn't
change her when they got older had thou opened it sooner no
harm would have befallen any uh what is it what do you want
hmm come let us enter is so cute he's like hey hey wait at
least let me make some room for you
steps begin to falter the spaceship's workshop is cluttered
with countless tools and weapons leaving barely any space to
walk eventually scarlet stops you could have told me you
were coming to visit yeah had i done so thou wouldest have
striven to avoid me what i've heard from Dorothy.
Since the departure of the Red Hood, thou has sequestered
thyself within the workshop, refusing to leave for the wolf.
She's a neat noun.
I do not claim to ken what lieth within my heart, yet now is
not the time for... Aw.
She became a neat.
Mankins dressed in them are strangely familiar.
Oh my god, wait, what?
Her gaze never leaving the outfits.
Oh my god, like friends oh no i was planning on showing them
to you once they were finished oh okay no she didn't make
okay i was gonna say did she like build her own friends
aren't these new outfits for rapunzel and myself oh she
built them armor more like equipment than an oh i thought it
was like some wilson you know where she she painted a
volleyball with a face on it like you're my new friend how
splendid do you like it oh very much so like an engineer
like armory i'm glad but what possessed thee to make these
well the battle's going to get a lot tougher from here on
out i don't think they expected the war to last a hundred
years we don't know when lilith will return and there could
be another heretic like anachiro out there we have to be
ready snow white why are you looking at me in despair then
hmm what i am filled with sorrow i miss red hood i miss her
so much already see she's such a suitor right all red hood
did was bully her she's like yeah but that's tough love good
terms i can't afford to wallow in despair aren't thou
burying that sorrow deep within thy bosom and continuing on
wait what wait oh wait no no by auto wait like rewind what
did you just say scarler excuse me far too much as a child
and unfairly so in her where pause never mind think not of
it okay where is it art thou bring that that sword deep
within that bosom in any case about these attire i'm 12.
one of dorothy and I'm 13.
Sorry, you two, I have not 12.
I'm not 12.
I'm 13.
Uh, yes.
I figured I should start with the ones that have the highest
priority.
Low.
By those very words, thou dost acknowledge that I surpass
Dorothy in strength.
Same.
Yeah.
Fine, just.
But if thou were to attend first to us, how sorely
disappointed would the others be?
Uh, I actually started with the ones who take the most
damage.
or are frequently injured oh is that red hood hmm oh wait
that's what she made it for start yeah i'm gonna say it is
no matter all is well she's like okay i'm sure whose
foolishly large firearm be that none among us would write to
be fair she has a sword like of course she's gonna take the
most damage that's i made a promise to someone like the
scheme is about shooting things and yet she has a sword
working on it whenever i can hmm though the recipient
remains unknown to me, yet they are the luckiest soul in all
the world.
To be the beneficiary of a weapon crafted by the most
accomplished artisan.
You flatter me.
There you are.
There I am.
That was quick.
You did get a chance to talk some sense into her, right?
Huh.
This won't do.
As the acting leader, I'll...
Thou shall not treat snow white as a child but she is me why
are you yelling all of a sudden but she is a child into you
Snow white is snow white is Is that why she got upgrades?
Dorothy Prithy step out and spar with me for a moment My
blood fulminates within me and I must needs quell it Fight
me 1v1 me now with all haste before this fire within me
fades one v1 me now No, thanks The one thing I hate the most
is getting sweaty Very well then standing still how you part
of the army Oh my oh my out you're good at playing by
yourself So why don't you do that instead That's the pope
that Throw thy own heads Wait that's excuse me but what just
happened bro What
playing by herself how could you say such a thing oh you see
my oh shit you see my cursor you see my I thought you guys
don't see my cursor
wait what happened very well I shall contend alone do but
grant me thine audience goodness gracious oh god
decency decency I suggest you stop talking I that would be
best huh you're not going to keep going he's like why why I
got already got so excited for nothing it's not fair he's
like I don't understand why won't you you fight!
Alright.
Guys, you think I'm gonna make it, guys?
Can't believe it.
Gaze upon me, my audience.
Alright, see, watch this.
See, okay, now you can see my cursor.
Look at that.
Boom!
Whoa!
I'm playing the game, guys.
Look at that.
And then...
Real easy.
Oh, she got eliminated because Red Hood gave her dirty mags.
What's with the delay?
Ping!
It's just ping, guys.
It's just ping.
Oh, hey.
British lady is Lily West you're awake commander where are
we we're in the repair center hmm so what do you think is
the central government's repair facility any different
softer beds perhaps or maybe the air is cleaner all hospital
rooms are the same that is not true it depends on where you
get going That's if it's a private or public hospital, too.
And if you have insurance or not.
What did they say?
Wait, do Nikes have insurance?
How much time do I have left?
I don't know.
What's wrong with my brain?
You could live another hundred years.
Don't joke around.
I'm just trying to hold on to hope.
Hope is important.
Do we need insurance?
Maybe.
Less if you push yourself too hard.
Less?
Half a year?
What does she have?
So there's really no other way.
Wait, what does she have?
She's a...
She's a Niki.
What does she have?
Why is she dying?
There's no cure?
Does she have terminal?
Like, is there something in her brain?
Does she have, like, tumors growing in her brain?
They built it without even knowing how to fix it.
Her body is dying?
Niki's brains have an expiration?
Oh.
she didn't yeah i was gonna say she oh she was like
literally the first one oh this body was intended for
short-term battles after all wait but why can't we just
transfer transport her brain to another nike the problem is
that the war has dragged on for too long yeah like she
doesn't know there's a hundred more years do you think we'll
be victorious in six months time not a chance losing though
that's possible as expected Oh, she is the goddess.
Yeah, transferred the SSC.
Sure, we're undefeated, but there are fewer than 10 of us in
this squad.
All we can do now is serve as a symbol of hope for humanity
on the battlefield.
Well, we certainly pulled that off admirably.
Yeah, maybe too admirably.
We've already become the hope of humanity.
So you've got to stay alive.
I wish it were that simple.
I expected this.
But it's happening too quickly.
I wish I'd left something behind for the others.
Just leave your brain.
Yeah.
When the end starts to draw near, I guess people start
thinking the same things.
If I were to die tomorrow, I wouldn't care what anyone
thought.
What's the point in leaving anything behind?
I'm barely able to take care of my own matters as it is.
So what would you do?
Let's see.
Drink some fine liquor with a beauty on each other.
Hmm.
Yeah.
While you're flanked by two beautiful women?
Why not?
Every story needs an audience.
I hope that wish of yours comes true.
I'm gonna try my best.
So how did the meeting go?
It hasn't even started yet.
Not yet.
Why not three?
Because you collapsed.
Is it really necessary for me to attend?
Why limit yourself, man, if you're dying?
Why not four?
had to say too uh i think i know what they're going to bring
up i think you're right only two hours it looks like the end
is coming yeah there's nothing we can do about that it's
inevitable one can sit on the lap i really don't like it me
neither too much greed ruins the meal that's good that's
actually good
Yeah.
Wait, actually I want to know.
All right, I want to try reloading.
Nice.
Good job, Snow White.
Yay!
We did it.
Two days later.
She's still alive.
commander yes may I hit that wall no you can't not until
I've had my turn there are multiple walls oh no meeting was
bad and suffer like a dog just for this to happen oh no
after
some time gasping for bread bro this guy needs to work up
more are you finished he's just kicking the wall and he's
breathless already holy shit okay she just broke the entire
thing hope that wasn't a support beam
what should i do i can't shake off my anger hold it in yeah
i'm going to cry you shame him it down for it that's true to
come back the word commander wore it down
there expressions change goddess
sad attention salute in perfect unison at ease gentlemen to
need a goddess herself in person what an incredible honor to
truly a great honor indeed it's all this nonsense about
honor what are we a cult my apologies sir it's just such an
It's literally an army.
What the fuck do you mean?
I shall sever this worthless tongue at once.
I forgot what?
These fanatics are the worst.
I can't stand them.
He didn't even say no.
He's like, okay.
Bro, stop him.
He's gonna cut his tongue out.
Same here.
He didn't even stop them.
It's truly an honor to meet the likes of you two who have
always fought on behalf of all humanity.
Jesus.
Well, it's not like we're the only ones fighting.
Judging by that insignia, you're a platoon leader you're
doing your part too oh no compared to the great work you two
are doing my contributions are utterly insignificant i'm
pathetic worthless this is exhausting indeed i don't deserve
to be seen by you as to what caused this hole in the wall if
there's been any inconveniences at all please tell me bro
come down no matter what it takes
Honk and Mecha Destructor came out of nowhere and smashed a
hole in the...
Ow!
Hey, stop pinching me.
Don't you realize how strong you are?
That's more like a vice than a pinch.
He's like, I deserve it.
I'm worthless.
I'm barely a man.
Can I?
True.
He's seeing his O-Shoot right now.
Yikes.
Shading to give him a super chat.
Nicky.
Oh.
Oh, JP Dubb is Mecha Gorilla.
That's...
My lips are sealed.
Excuse me.
But who told you that?
No one told me per se.
But an anonymous person started spreading it on the central
government's intranet.
The central government's intranet.
Hmm.
Oh my god, even emojis?
Commander, may I have a word with you?
Stop fooling around, Lily Weiss.
We don't have any time to spare.
Get it together.
We still have work to do.
I'm leaving this situation in your hands, Platoon Leader.
If you'll excuse me, I have something to take care of.
They just leave him.
They didn't tell him not to cut off his tone.
He's pacing.
Before long, they're both practically running down the
corridor.
The man watches them as they recede into the distance.
So cool.
He's so cool.
cool and this is how the commander died yes now it's my turn
to take over oh my gosh i heard there's like what 14
chapters right all right well i'm getting it's catching up
the power level is catching
up you want to get caught by the mecca gorilla oh 12 yeah
it's a lot of content for new year they always do that for
the big updates like there's a lot of content for update
Which makes sense, you know?
Oh,
shit.
Okay.
I brought a dog to the battlefield.
Yeah, 12.
And it's only part one, too.
Because part two is releasing.
And I believe...
Let me check again.
Part two is coming out on...
I don't know if it's follow-up on January 6th, guys.
This is just part one of the story.
yeah i made it yeah next week
oswald watches the stream of people and supplies pour into
the entrance of the ark a line of people stretches on
endlessly as the supply trucks continue rolling in oswald
suddenly filled with sense of unnews has always has there
always been this many people and this much supplies in this
world It feels like still everything and everyone on the
entire planet has gathered here.
Doctor, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you for playing Niki.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Always enjoy playing Niki whenever they ask me.
I want to check out the new update.
It's always fun.
I'm like, actually, every sponsor, I'm learning the lore
little by little.
Virtual never open again.
Neither from the inside nor from the outside.
enemy's defeat has managed to survive.
The fate of the entire speech sees hinges upon the success
of this operation.
As Oswald thinks of his role as the one responsible for
sealing the ark, the ziziness returns.
On a day of his appointment, he could sense the jealousy
hidden behind the smiles of his peers and superiors who
congratulated him, but such things no longer matter.
Once the ark is sealed, it cannot be reopened, not even from
within.
anyone enter it.
After the five-step sealing process, those who come seeking
refuge in this utopia will find only silent gates greeting
them before they perish.
When the time comes, Oswald must shut the doors.
He will have to turn a blind eye to those who come hoping
for rescue.
He'll be an executioner.
No, a mass murderer.
He has always followed orders from above about question.
Even when those orders required him to dirty his hands.
He never refused or diso- A good soldier always follows
order.
That's a good soldier right there.
As a result of his work, he has somehow earned the nickname,
Hellhound.
It is a name far from glorious, yet he feels content.
After all, it means he is being recognized.
Oswald the Hellhound believes no one is more suited than him
to be in charge of sealing the Ark.
All he has to do is follow orders from his superiors, as he
always has.
It's supposed to be an easy task.
But then...
There are too many.
I'll look once more at the endless line of people.
How many people are supposed to be allowed into the Ark?
What percentage of the total population is it?
I'm eating a cough drop.
Not even that.
Perhaps a single digit or merely a fraction.
And what about the rest?
What will happen to them?
Just don't look at their faces so you don't humanize them.
He sure won't be able to endure much longer.
Everything has been planned by his superiors.
Everything must proceed as outlined.
Even contingency measures are already in pity place.
But he is the one who must make the decision.
To abandon the majority of all humankind.
In that moment, he desperate tries to recall who will assist
him in sealing the Ark.
The goddesses?
The hope of mankind?
The goddesses of victory?
He said the thing!
During the sealing of the Ark, the goddesses will stand
guard as part of Operation Ark Guardian!
That'll do it for now.
Oh my god!
They are the Ark Guardian!
Title jump!
Oswald has been saved by the goddesses more times than you
can count.
Roll credits!
Even thousands of times.
Beginning focus, Oswald takes out his tablet and looks at
the status screen.
a shadow appears.
But lost in thought, he fails to notice his approach.
Bane Composer, he stays still for a moment and quickly draws
his guns and points it straight ahead.
Wow.
Where did this gun come from?
That's so strange.
That's a child.
Hi, Mr. Are you busy?
Hello.
Let's have some fun.
Okay.
Sorry, apparently I am I'm back in war, guys.
Yeah, apparently I am.
Sorry, little kid.
I thought I'd do this war thing for a bit.
That's crazy.
When they shut the gates, they're like...
They make the goddesses stand there.
Knowing, like, seeing, like, all the people that they're not
letting in.
This is a truly beautiful story this was.
I am most pleased with it.
Oswald lowers his weapon.
are you names freesia we met before when red hood saved us
oh hey kid what's your name freesia okay freesia where are
your mom and dad they're red hood please time and place
please they got sick it only happened recently hmm you don't
have to don't have to flex those It's over.
I do, but it's okay.
I was able to say goodbye to them.
They were sick for a long time.
You don't need to do the pose.
About things we liked.
Oh, this is a red ash.
We didn't like.
We talked about all sorts of stuff.
So that's okay.
I'm sure my mom and dad are in a happier place.
Yeah!
Do you have their brains?
Maybe you can put them in the robot.
Okay, maybe a cyborg did.
I remember now.
What is it?
This area is off limits to civilians.
Oh, nothing much.
Gotta show dominance.
Showed his finger here.
And that's been folded in half.
Can you sign here for me?
You want me to sign it?
Yes.
You want, she wants his autograph.
Looks at the paper, Frisia, is holding out.
A guardian consent form?
Why are you giving this to me?
Wait, he's just got her guardian?
I want you to be my guardian.
I should choose you.
I can't do that.
Yeah, I was going to say.
It might be best if you can find someone suitable among
those heading to the ark.
I don't think that's how it works, little girl.
You have to let the adults choose the orphan.
I'm sorry.
That's how bureaucracy works in this world.
Everyone who came here with me already has family.
I mean, they can adopt another.
There's no limits.
a mom, a brother, or a sister.
Not all, don't worry.
You can be the other sister.
But I don't have anyone.
Reverse, yeah, reverse adoption.
When I showed this to them, all of them had an awkward look
on their face.
Oh, she did ask them.
I don't want to make anyone feel put out.
Oh.
But they said if I don't have a guardian, I'll be sent to an
orphanage.
And I don't want that.
I'm scared.
even know anyone there so i want you to be my guardian the
random single man i don't know you either yeah he's gonna
say he doesn't even know her oh that's so sad oh there's no
manual for situations like this he's here's at phrygia this
expression is confident fearless and unwavering against our
reason, feels quite certainly that this girl will be fine.
I'm sorry.
I can't be your guardian.
Bro, she has no family.
She's like, you'll be fine.
Bro, Oswald!
Oh my god!
That's so messed up.
Russell.
Frisia's hands, holding out the paper, tremble ever so
slightly.
Oswald looks at Frisia once more.
Her face appears calm, indifferent to success, yet he
notices her shoulders and legs quiver almost imperceptibly.
Oswald thinks of the goddess squad, those who held him up
whenever he was about to fall.
Don't fall for it, Oswald.
No, don't fall for it.
my god he fell for it present the seal to the administrator
it should make things easier for you yeah he got baited are
you okay with this what do you mean becoming my guardian
look it was it was messed up that he was like no but then
the fact that he didn't stick with it you know you should
might as well like he gave her trauma by saying no first you
know well i'm not sure either thanks mr truly thank you i'm
truly so grateful Oh.
Can I stay here by your side for a while?
He's just like, oh, what do I do?
The child's crying.
I'll be quiet.
I won't say anything.
Go and submit that document to the administrator.
Oh, right.
I'll be right back.
That won't be necessary.
Oh my god, he stepped up.
He messed with her for a little bit, though.
He messed with her a little bit.
I mean, like, JK, No, JK, haha, I guess I'll adopt you.
Three figures approach from afar.
How are you, special agent?
Sorry, chief.
I'm good.
What's the matter?
Oh, nothing serious.
This child brought a guardian consent form bearing your
signature and seal, so I wanted to stop by to verify it.
I'm telling you it's true.
He signed it and stamped it himself.
Putting aside her current plight, we plan to launch an
investigation regarding this forgery.
I was the one who signed it and stamped it.
Yes, we'll be sure to be thorough in our investment.
I beg your pardon.
I signed and stamped those documents myself.
Damn.
You did?
That's correct.
See, I told you it's true.
I was going to say, how would this orphan forge this thing?
Forge a government signature and stamp.
However...
blue marker his eyes clear why did you why did what the fuck
is around with you bro why did you sign it understood i
verified its authenticity as per regulations an adult male
is actually not permitted to serve as a child's soul
gardener is that so yes it's essentially no different from
however since it's you chief it won't be oh your credentials
are beyond reproach could be a single father with processing
the paperwork yeah I was gonna say he needs a wife your time
sorry to have troubled you I should have handled this in
person I appreciate all your hard work humanity's gum is not
too late well that's the thing with humanity gone you have
to be a dad you got to repopulate the world
urch until his head in but decides against it.
A certain someone still has her eyes on him.
He's like, yay!
I adopted a father.
I know.
I'll be quiet as a mouse.
I won't make a peep.
Oh, she's gonna see him start rejecting people.
She's gonna see him commit his first war crime.
His pirate remains squarely fixated on the girl that I saw
because of her.
mind finds a brief escape from its tangled web of thoughts
what a great like first day for her no like daddy's first
war crime you know she's gonna see it it's true though he's
gonna throw right there like we gotta close the door you
know for like and leave like thousands of people out to die
and she's gonna see it it's a peak yeah exactly it's peak
bonding I get more white flowers?
Oh, I have to replenish.
Wait, the shop has one.
I remember.
I could do one more.
Oh, billions.
Oh, yeah, billions.
Okay, I'll do one more replenish.
I have extra.
Oh, I can't...
The story is pretty interesting so far.
I'm actually enjoying the story.
Oh, wait, I could have just bought...
Just grabbed these.
Wait, whoops.
It's not what I wanted.
I'm just clicking everything.
We're here.
Yeah, I like the story so far.
I trust you, troublemakers, behaved while I was away.
There you are.
You're late.
What hath detained me thus?
Are you both all right?
Speak one at a time, people.
I heard something major happened while we were gone.
You guys held the fort well.
Great job.
Pish posh.
It was an easy feat.
Yeah, bring your kid to work, Jay.
Ah!
Yes.
She departed without any regrets.
And we gave her a proper send-off.
Good.
That's all that matters.
It's a pity I couldn't say goodbye to her.
Oh well.
There'll be other chances.
Huh?
I hate to start barking orders so soon after arriving, but I
need everyone to gather in the meeting room.
I have an urgent announcement.
She's telling them that she's dying!
She's telling him that she has terminal Ligma Precisely
Alright, let's go
She says Oh wait, no, it's just up No, she's not Okay, never
mind Ever she will never open Again on either side Arc
Guardian A defense mission led by the goddess squad Who will
protect the arc's entrance Until the final ceiling is
complete Her voice remains steadfast Oh, this is worse dude
oh this is where they're gonna start seeing the billions of
people that get that get locked up comes to an end that's it
any questions so when do we head in during the final phase
of the sealing process the same goes for the mass-produced
nike units we'll defend the entrance until the very last
moment then enter the arc all right how long will it take
until the fifth phase is complete thank you thank you don't
give my birthday to get and I love to get a birthday wish
from you thank you for being young for giving us the dragons
lots of happiness and laughter thank you for the super chat
Adam of course of course it's always a pleasure to uh to
stream for you guys and make you guys have great memories
and laughter with me uh happy birthday to you happy birthday
to you have birthday dear Adam happy birthday to you yay
happy birthday I don't know depending on the situation at
hand even in the worst case scenario it shouldn't take more
than a month oh that's rather short yes it is in addition
since this operation is purely defensive in nature the wings
of victory will be moved to the ark what will happen during
the third phase that's war planning time even our dedicated
transport base shall be taken from us is there some cause
for dividing this Okay.
There's a limit to how many people the Ark can take at one
time.
So they're splitting the procedure into separate phases to
ensure safety.
It's just a fine way of saying the Highborn mean to enter
first.
Hmm.
It's not just about the people.
That's right.
The Ark has dozens of entrances, which act as supply
channels.
Since the supply is also need to be continually brought in
until the very last moment.
Yeah, so to feed everyone.
Step by step.
This process will make quite a ruckus, which will naturally
attract the raptures.
It's our job to hold them back.
There are dozens of entrances, you say?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Then why is there only one for humans?
It's likely due to the selection process.
Only those who are chosen may enter.
Anyone else cannot.
So I guess, like, those who can't enter are gonna die by the
rapture here.
They can't let just anyone in.
Once the first phase is complete, you gotta have a PhD.
What about those who arrive at the Ark's entrance afterward?
And those left on the surface?
What happens to them?
They're to be abandoned.
Oh, you know what happens to them.
Since we lost the battle, we can't save everyone.
See, yippee, trauma bonding.
Left for dead.
Yay, trauma bonding.
Let's go.
You know as well as I do, that's impossible.
There's no way we can even get close to the lift.
Yeah, there can be a distraction, too.
Not even if every person on the planet rushed it at the same
time.
What then, pray?
Are we to tuck our tails betwixt our legs like hounds
defeated and slink into the depths below?
Yeah.
So what do you want us to do?
We lost, girl!
Go ahead and bring me the queen's head yourself, then.
We lost!
Stop throwing a fit, Scarlet.
A fit?
Me?
We're part of the loss.
They'll be all, meaning adjourned.
If you've got any complaints or questions, come to me.
However, think through what you want to say before you do.
If you intend to come to me simply to whine, don't bother.
I mean, she was part of the loss, too.
Let's go, Lilith.
Yes, Commander.
So it's not like she didn't know.
Like...
All right, here we go.
Whatever.
I'll just do what I can.
Alright, pew pew pew Don't worry We transported in this case
from the future To the past for this exact mission Wait, why
is she in the front?
Are you okay?
Wait, is she supposed to be in the front?
Wait, is she okay?
I was thinking, I was like Why is she there by herself?
What a truly beautiful story This was.
I was like, Girl, take cover, girl!
The whole point is to take cover no but it's fine i was like
is she supposed to be there i was like
all right nice it's
all right this this rabbit is not okay oh no i think
bringing a rabbit is It's not ideal in the battlefield.
I'll get you to your destination.
Oh my god.
Coffee?
My god, okay.
Yeah, that rabbit definitely has PTSD.
Yay!
I did it.
Alright.
Wait.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, we're still mad okay we just came back from a fight and
she's still mad all right rather than beating up the table
why don't you say something yeah i am merely venting is that
forbidden of course it's not truth be told i'd love to do
the same is there truly no other way it's as you said the
only option left is to defeat the queen and i don't think
that's gonna happen because she is alive in the third year
anniversary so I don't think they did it I don't think they
won a hundred years ago so I am rendered a defeated hound
tail tucked as I flee even so we can still save the ones
within our reach that's what we have to do we don't have
enough supplies we can't and what if we save like someone
that doesn't have a phd yeah so let's not think of it as
losing but a temporary retreat
hmm what why is everyone looking at me like that because
you're the most mature among us yeah i guess i mean she is
sort of what we can she doesn't speak with emotions we might
up losing what we already have in our hands we must
understand our own limits all of us but if there had been a
way the commander and lilith wouldn't have stood idle
they've accepted it and moved on so should we our duty is to
strive for the best possible outcome in our current
situation don't be one of those people who rage when there's
no solution wait it's one with a lottery that's
No, there's no helping it.
What if the guy that's gonna...
The guy that's gonna cure cancer didn't win the lottery.
What if the guy who invented Nikes didn't win the lottery?
Why am I so feeble thus?
Indeed.
Come now, Dorothy.
Twas but a passive remark.
Technically, yes.
Surely thou dost not truly deem me weak.
You can't even remember what you said a moment ago.
Well, too bad.
with me for a moment very well come again you told me to
step outside with you oh I mean to cross blades with thee
fine let's do it she's gonna 1v1 Rapunzel Rapunzel look oh
my god Rapunzel look the moment she loses you're gonna 1v1
me then prepare to prostrate thyself and admit defeat.
Dorothy smiled.
My apologies.
Oh my god, she likes it.
That was simply too absurd.
I couldn't help myself.
Oh my god, she's crazy.
Oh, oh, she's you could tell she's crazy.
That's not, that's a serial killer smile right there.
That's a serial killer smile.
That ain't a regular smile.
I Will protect my passengers Oh, where are the enemies?
I forgot I remember I saw like a video where like you're
supposed to like I think it's like first you um The story
will be rewritten like how to know you have a serial killer
smile Where you have to like hide your hide your eyes or
some you smile and then like I remember I remember this step
There's like a video trend where they're like, how do you
know if you have a serial killer smile?
And then what?
I don't remember.
I watched a video like months ago.
I truly hate this.
What exactly do you hate?
There was one where I do remember it where it's like, if you
can...
There's like a song that plays, and if you can like move
from one end, from one side, if your eyes can follow from
one side to the other smoothly, then you're like, there's a
chance you're a serial killer.
killer like but you know it's like because it's like it's
not like it's not like snappy it's just a smooth like left
to right if you're startled can't you at least react like
you are you have the killer genes I didn't think anyone else
didn't you hear I even not oh it's like this dumb tick-tock
trends it's like The witch dress, yeah.
She's can move her eyes left to right smoothly.
Not bad.
You're beginning to show the qualities of the next leader.
I learned from watching you.
And remember, I'm not a danger right now.
You move your eyes from left to right.
They're like, it's like super snappy.
It's like, it's like, snap, snap, snap.
You can't do it like a smooth.
It's really hard to do a very smooth transition from left to
right.
She found out!
Hmm?
Lilith, you don't mean...
Surely not.
Six months.
Tops!
She found out!
Seriously?
If you're surprised, can you at least act like it?
Is there really no alternative?
Wait, I just... do... Burn him!
He's a serial killer!
Prunim!
But, given the situation, that's not really an option you
should retire at once and get some rest you know i can't do
that are you going to tell everyone i have six months to
live you gotta rest bro it's not like she can fucking get
better dorothy are you stupid you should at least you should
you should rest as a male how if that's the right thing to
do do you want her to endure the same pain twice i'm not
sure that kid can handle it snow white's not a kid anymore
she's just haven't upgraded her since then to me everyone is
still a kid even me i'm only telling you this because i
don't think you are sometimes i wish people would treat me
like a kid too i understand she's like the adult
responsibilities me too george do you need to keep this in
mind if anything happens i'll be counting of we've got the
commander he is likely going to be the one who breaks down
the hardest he's playing it cool now but i'm sure of it
sorry for dropping all that on you out of nowhere when have
you not so future leader what is it you hate so much oh so
she nominated her myself huh i hate myself i'm stuck in this
loop of self-loathing Hello?
I didn't see this coming.
She hates herself.
Hmm.
When all this is over, when the Ark is sealed, we will
return and be lauded as heroes, the ones who defended
humanity to the end.
Goddesses are victory.
Humanities hope.
Our legacy will live on forever.
It might even turn into a myth someday.
And then maybe someday we'll play video games based off this
legend.
still be celebrated as heroes back in the Ark.
And I'll live with that fact, fully content.
Oh, eh.
Telling myself that our fight, my fight, was not in vain.
That's what I hate.
Everyone wants something different out of this.
I know.
I still don't like it.
So you're just doing things half-heartedly?
Of course not.
Then you're good.
There won't be any issues in that case.
Thanks.
You're the only one I could speak to about such things.
And now you're leaving.
Oh.
Yeah, it looks like it.
I mean, she'll still be here for six months.
Can't stop that.
I don't want to either.
That's too damn bad.
Oh, hello, Snow White.
Snow White.
And?
What's wrong?
Is there something about the operation you don't understand?
Oh, no.
It's not that.
How are you doing?
Are you okay?
Of course.
Why would I not be?
Oh, it's just... You seem a little different from your usual
self.
Different?
How?
Nothing's changed.
Just the vibe, I guess.
Hey, look at me.
I look all right, don't I?
She's very healthy.
You're the same, Lilith, as always.
So full of hope and optimism.
I know exactly.
Look at her.
She's so happy right now.
So innocent.
Look at you worrying about me.
Oh, God.
She's blushing, too.
You're so adorable.
I'm not a kid anymore.
You're not?
Then who is this small, adorable person starting?
that why she got her upgrades i said stop she wanted it to
be taken seriously
what oh my stress just melted away what what what was that
i'm dying what what was that okay is that like her inner
thoughts sleep tight that was so sudden yes that's her
intrusive thoughts i was like what the I'm dying.
And then like, she's like, hello.
Yay.
Yippee.
Thank you, game, for the reminder that she's dying.
You have to tell me, all right?
Yeah, so sudden.
Of course.
Oh.
Down the corridor, where is her face in her house?
She's feeling sad.
I don't want to die.
Oh.
No one does, girl.
That is...
sacrifices have to be made.
Oh.
Alright, we're going to have to call it here, guys.
But, if you guys want to know more about the story, this is
part one.
Remember, this is part one that just came out yesterday.
But if you guys want to check out the story yourself and...
see what happens next feel free to click on the link pinned
in my chat um or in the description below and check it out
yourself yeah i got you on the cliffhanger didn't i that's
right that's right i got you with the cliffhanger uh but the
story was really interesting so far i um it was actually it
was really pretty sad um um and it's only part one so that
means part two uh it's It's going to come out next week on
January 6th, and the event ends on January 19th.
Don't forget.
Oh, yeah.
I also have a union.
Join my, join my, join my union.
I handed the leader to someone else because like to someone
that had like the highest amount of playtime, because
apparently if you don't log in frequently, it like, it like
gives it to someone else.
So I did it before I didn't want to get kicked.
So, yeah, so it's called Food Files.
And my number, my only rule, my only rule, if you want to
join my union, is that you don't feed your Nikes.
Because I think that's a waste of food.
You got to feed the humans first.
I think we have, oh yeah, we still have some spots left.
We have six spots left, and you want to join the Food Files
Union.
Um, but yeah, tomorrow, tomorrow, it, uh, uh, tomorrow, a
lot of stuff is dropping in tomorrow for the event.
Um, there is new character, Snow White, heavy arms.
Like I said, I'll show you guys the character right now.
There's, I went straight to the liberation.
Alright, this is what she looks like now.
She took off her armor.
Because now she's stronger.
so this is her now look at that now she's all grown up she
got even more upgrades guys she got even more upgrades if
you're a new kid what will your weapon be most likely an smg
i think smgs would be the easiest for me forum thank you the
super chat thank you so she's dropping tomorrow um alice is
getting a new cost costume and Alice and Emma are both
getting a new costume as well as uh what's uh Quincy um are
you is the new costume in the game yet or no chat let me
check I'm gonna check real quick Alice
oh we can view it all right oh I think it's what's the
costume I'll show you guys the costume real Oh, that's cute.
That one's cute.
Costume tab?
Oh.
Wait.
Costumes.
There you go.
Put on.
Try and remember where it is.
How do I check the...
I don't know if the new costumes are in here.
I can't search it up, so I can't tell.
whoa oh here it is this one what is this one no that's true
oh wait I did it this is the new costume this is the there
are so many of your friends here this is the new costume for
Alice that's cut dropping tomorrow so cute oh my god
and then oh wait I can just search it from here.
Let's look at Emma.
Whoa.
Look at tactical upgrade.
Costume tab.
No, that's not.
Wait, no, that's not the new costume.
It is.
What is it called?
Secret therapy.
That's not here.
Wait, where is secret therapy?
that is that's secret therapy I thought it was like about oh
wait I looked at the wrong one oh okay yeah I see it yeah I
see it now that is here yeah what the fuck it oh my god so
this costume is dropping tomorrow sorry I was looking that's
a different one I was looking at a squad one ma'am do you
need help holding that i have two very strong hands right
now i don't worry ma'am i can help you if you need anything
just let me know okay oh my god she was hiding oh my god if
you need anything just let me know okay it's okay she
doesn't have to worry about recoil guys
She has me.
I does not have to worry about Ricla.
All right.
But like I said, costumes are dropping tomorrow.
Guys, if you guys want to grab some of these costumes.
And then Quincy.
All right.
This is her new costume.
Whoa.
Don't call me a thief.
Oh, she's a thief.
I'm on the side of justice.
Oh, she's cute.
But this is her new costume.
She's a ballerina.
There are so many things here worth swiping.
Oh, don't worry.
This bird moves so fast can't help.
I didn't even think it was super chat.
Thank you.
But this also is dropping tomorrow as well.
I am just admiring.
Admiring those sweet ass guns right there, you know?
That's a good gun right there.
Look at, I mean, look at it.
Look at the mag, the amount of bullets you can have.
Guys.
oh my god the the boat i wonder how much ammo she has in
that gun guys look at that i can aim for days without
reloading chat yeah yeah there's a nice pair of silas mac
10s exactly that's those are some good ass mac 10s right
there yeah but not only that um uh for the part of the new
year celebration they are giving away uh not giving away but
you know they there are like 103 pulls you can obtain as
well as you know like i said this is a new campaign the art
guardian the new event of the art guardians um but yeah
let's thank you again to nikki for sponsoring me for the end
of the year new year event um it's nice to end 2025 with the
with nikki uh they've been supporting me for so long so
thank you again um you guys want to support this stream as
well as the sponsor feel free to click on the link um pin in
chat and description it really does help out a lot um but i
hope you guys have been enjoying the story so far if you
guys want to learn more about the story like see it all the
way to the end remember to make sure to download and check
out the game um i did i did stop at a very intense
cliffhanger for you guys so Uh, anyway, guys, as always,
everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move
around to get that blood flowing, and if you stay up for me,
head to bed, because you deserve it.
Yes, she knows I'm leaving.
Little Mermaid's, little Mermaid's like, don't leave, I'm
gonna be all alone, she knows, she knows I'm about to end,
like, yeah, there's a lot of plot.
I mean, the plot was, I think that's the thing about Niki,
the plot is always, like, the writing is always, like,
really, really good.
just the gameplay guys there's also a really good story that
comes with it um and if you're a beginner if you're like a
new player they're very generous with like polls and stuff
in the beginning and also like they have lots of events and
stuff too so um you can just like farm for you just farm for
stuff that you wanted to um but anyways i'll see you guys
next time tomorrow it's gonna be a very interesting a very
fun stream i hope you guys support it a lot of hard work
goes went into Tomorrow's New Year countdown stream.
I really look forward to seeing all of you guys there.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye.
As I expected, it's lonely with no one else around.